how's it go what gun man
my spear back we're gonna play some
state of decay cuz I'm not your hombre
you thought else anyway I had no [ __ ]
clue what to play today and I had this
game it's pretty funny
hey how you doing
Oh shet sigh you're crazy
okay you're not you might be on to
something
stay down Sam B scum stupid stupid
stupid stupid oh this game is fun whoa
yes it [ __ ] bit me see Madison can I
welcome this okay
whoa what the what okay it's one of
those games huh alright well he told us
to go here no that's a fish [ __ ] so
what's your name sorry great name
the game actually looks kind of fancy
but man is it funky it's funkier than my
granddad's pants and those are pretty
good I am funky I had like rainbows and
[ __ ] go to rages station five years
being here background noises way man the
mouth sensitivity is out of my ass a
roof out of the roof okay what have we
got in here breasts as a dead guy hi
there dead guy I can't loot anything
oh no zambese why why Oh what are you
doing hugging him you don't hug Sammy's
idiot why would you hug is a me maybe
that's it maybe the zambese just needs
some love present to finish off alright
that's cool ever know everyone is like
oh your dog is so cute no it's not it's
not [ __ ] cute
okay it's pretty cute what who said that
the guy who'd jump through the window
injured people here I have to tend to
okay we'll see what we can do
all right finally we can get some
supplies hi guys what do we got
absolutely nothing thank you for the
supplies sir
now here we go okay I'll take this it
looks like we got all this to please so
I guess I call caps to perform emotes
I'm holding caps do the emote that's a
great mo right there search the cabins
but there's a miss all right let's be
very careful we don't want no trouble
now [ __ ]
where they call someone an [ __ ] in
they don't know [ __ ] okay I think they
might see us I'm not too sure that they
might think I'm a tree I wonder move
into a bush while crouched to hide
completely oh he'll never see me now
idiots oh [ __ ] what is that guy doing
all right here we go
okay we're fine it's all good easy easy
swing that sword just like I swing your
mom's get how you doing it I want glowy
ice bank Dombey apocalypse has got to be
like the best thing that could ever
happen either you become a zombie and
have go glowy bad as ice or two you get
to kill zombies with glowy bad as I what
are you doing stop being a [ __ ] I like
that zombie he doesn't see us [ __ ]
[ __ ] zombies
what am i doing the [ __ ] am i doing what
is this what are you doing what are you
doing stop stop it sir dude this ain't
no Brokeback Mountain okay
I'm not gonna do that [ __ ] with you
sorry all right here we go I got my
stick and don't you dare think I'm gonna
use yours oh damn that feels good
[ __ ]
that's how you Dame's no I'm not gonna
do that sorry nope all right the game
told me to go anyw oh shut your little
dick stick what what is body go I think
it went inside him
nice that's his heart what is he doing
the hell is he doing you really don't
have anything better to do sir
goddamn you're useless what a pile of
crap whatever got here
let me just stare into this wooden thing
and I'll find some [ __ ] eventually yes
yes okay nice how do you know what about
this that's Pig pelvis sweet as hell
it's not even a pillow what do you know
about pillows come on let's be honest
let's bail be fine don't sing it don't
sing it don't do you have a bad day take
one down saying it's finally this place
is safe hi guys
place it's not the little exam is like
five feet away I don't even know how
long five feet is I'm just saying come
with me and watch my back come with me
and watch my back I'll never mind that
little son of a [ __ ]
all right I think I'm supposed to go
where the green dot is as watering [ __ ]
all right
let's start you just want to look in my
ass don't you I knew it well if take a
good look
mm-hmm working it ah [ __ ]
I'm the one who gets to look Asha I
can't that's too bad for you you idiot
you think it is god damn it hold a right
Martin okay I'm I'm surveying there's
something over there did I miss anything
yes there's a vehicle over there hey
what is he doing so creepy let's climb
down oh sorry sorry bro
sorry everybody how do I get down Edgar
stop god damn it all right let me jump
down now of course I Lewis did he climb
up - oh god damn Oh No wet oh oh [ __ ] oh
damn damn just Sam chew on this
sorry sorry I guess I try okay let's
focus we are going to go here yes
all right we're going there Sam it isn't
really a thread that much in this game I
mean they bit me isn't that kind of
weird now every time in horror games
they bite you but you never get infected
why do you hug him why I'm gonna kill
all your ex-boyfriends
there are you're all mine
what is happening oh [ __ ] that's a lot
of zimmy's hey girl how you doing
alright I'll get them from behind
oh man that sure was difficult I think
you should but I don't think I can tell
her sorry miss click okay why don't you
take over how's that mean I can play as
a girl I could play as a girl oh my god
oh [ __ ] I'm badass [ __ ] look at this
[ __ ] look at this what the [ __ ] alright
six out of thirty Cole we got to shoot
[ __ ]
can I shoot these guys I mean I want to
but I don't think I should all right
let's check the map it looks like we
need to go back to base I'm surprisingly
enjoying this game all 630 is my ammo
man I'm sorry all right that's the wrong
that's the robber top top the top to top
to top to top the top top top top top
top top and the top and a dot up top
chop chop chop chop chop the top two
chop chop I don't touch me chop tap tap
tap tap tap tap attack now that was easy
here we go the stairs wonderful
obviously not surprised maybe in the ice
machine I think in the ice machine he's
gonna bite him bite him bite him bite
him one guy
[Laughter]
that's the spirit
yeah that's what I'm gonna propose to no
no don't die
oh no he's probably just gonna slow us
down
I'm trying to shoot the zombie in the
butt but it doesn't seem too worried oh
sure all right he did it all right
ice machine I don't trust it he was dead
how the hell do you not realize there
are zombies there's a Me's it makes
perfect sense it baffles my mind that
they would be oblivious to as Amy
invasion everyone knows what as Amy
invasion is you haven't earned what to
greet Edie usually to earn to greet Edie
you could piss on him and he you
wouldn't piss him off literally food is
here hope you guys enjoy this episode
you're like if you're dead let me know
if you want part two and come on this is
come on meet kitty conquer those
sausages